welcome to this video Tiger Petrosian
Tiger Petrosian from Finland yeah okay I
wanted to do something else something
with the fianchetto he went for the g3
set up him champ lucky black asses weird
check let's let's try that tonight see
three years 94 Bishop d2 Queen B 6 now
that it's nothing spectacular but it's
so it's a playable line my Queen d2 is
like very very unassuming move let's see
what he plays I think 93 94 okay you can
just check it and really the night on
detour sir misplaced no it's nothing
like it's not better here but black has
no problems whatsoever
now he has to play some fairly unnatural
moves now it's probably the best so that
you can go to c3 later okay so probably
just be six and get the bishop out the
clumsy night on the two is really
White's problem after the screen trade
the night is really not having a good
square and it won't find a good one so
quickly I have Bishop e6 possibly to a
taxi form if he moves the night I need
to be a bit cautious as 97 but in
general there is this a DM and and what
what exactly is this time is time use a
chair that is so quite remarkable uh-huh
so Bishop f5 afore is what you want to
do I might want to play b3 i also have
night before which is not not crazy
okay let's do this and rook c8 this is
sort of winning a temple because I think
rookie one or something like that is in
order f3 looks ugly maybe it's not so
bad but
wow this guy is slower than I am that
sets really a rare feat he has spent
half of his time after 11 moves that's
at school I come on rook e1 f3 whatever
it's not that bad nice is connected he's
not disconnected no internet issue okay
finally this was the idea I wanted to
get in room c 8 quickly and busy I
here's where I want to go to but I
couldn't before because of the the
issues with the with the 97 okay I can
play Bishop b2 him nothing that may not
last thing that scares me a lot but it
should be quite ok from now maybe I
should have taken no it's not not a big
deal anyway
preparing for b5 ok let's take this I
wonder ever should take now but probably
not young better to to use this active
rook placement yeah maybe maybe two
maybe taking now I wonder cheeks and 94
maybe and not sure I hope that oops is
taking with the bishop and expect that
ha ok
I guess a three but ok I can take night
takes I have g5 yeah gee I also have g5
I thought that the sea fowl plays
sometimes something that will help me
but now it's not that great really not
okay
you can just take and play I know Bishop
d7 I Brooksie one ok now but I haven't
played as well this is definitely
nothing special but yes nine seconds
kata-kata jack Wow k Roxy five Jim I
don't know what it is is it is it equal
why my worse should be seven i have
ninety-seven not clear white boy friends
and yeah i mean i don't know what he was
doing it was so slow around here i'm
certainly okay I mean about women may be
equal ish ok I want I should take that's
the computers choice they are probably
because I'm quick here taking both pawns
of wrong the pawn and the bishop so this
is happening and now i have the quicker
play on the C file yeah this is what I
wanted to get in the game but but
somehow it didn't get it is quite
comparable but not not quite the same 95
maybe jan at the end there's really
check I have no advantage whatsoever
computer is on debt equal yeah but I
mean his time management was really
really crazy I mean I am slow but this
is like putting it to extremes okay well
thanks for watching